I think the human brain is a big complex
machine it's an amazing machine it's a
creative machine but it's still made up
of these neurons which are appear to be
computational units hooked up in amazing
ways the imagination as far as we can
tell is itself a kind of simulation when
we imagin things when Einstein was
imagining things in free fall he was
running a kind of simulation himself
running on this incredible computer
Which is far more sophisticated than any
computer that ourselves have developed
to date but you know AI is moving fast I
can't believe where it is now compared
to where it was 10 years ago I am your
fearful host Professor Brian keading of
the arthury Clark Center for human
imagination talking with a renowned
intellect and this is a real a real
treat and when I found out that his new
book was coming out I just had to get
him and it is none other than Professor
David Chalmer who first formulated the
problem of the hard problem of
Consciousness which we're going to get
to in a paper facing up to the problem
of Consciousness in way back in 1995
expanded upon it in his uh wonderful
book The conscious mind 96 his works are
provocative influential and and uh some
of the greatest luminaries of all time
including past guest step Pinker have
called it uh so praiseworthy and his ACC
claim and Renown know no bounds and so
first I want to welcome you today Dave
how are you doing today all the way in
New York thanks Brian yeah great to
great to be here it's kind of kind of
rainy out here but uh I hope it's hope
it's sunnier where you are yeah la Hoya
that's a fair game you know I usually
say you know the hardest job in the
world is being a San Diego sports caster
because we've never won a championship
in any sport but the easiest job is
being San Diego's meteorologist because
72 in Sunny 71 and a half in Sunny you
know it's it's uh it makes up for uh its
lack of of variance by its uh
consistency of beauty so yes it is quite
lovely but I am a native New Yorker I'm
a born and bred in New York so sometimes
the accent will come out um and Dave as
I told you right before we started my
audience loves it when I play the game
which we call judging books by their
covers and titles and subtitles so this
book has a butterfly very provocative
and beautiful butterfly which is kind of
the only character that makes its way
through a dream sequences throughout the
book uh the title reality plus the
subtitles Virtual Worlds and the
problems of philosophy they've explained
to us what is the title uh the meaning
of the title and that mischievous
butterfly doing on there the title is uh
is reality plus actually I started I had
a working title for a long time that was
reality
2.0 because this is about you know the
book is in large part about virtual and
artificial realities these could be the
uh the uh the second class of realities
first reality physical reality but then
we start creating our own artificial
realities that's reality 2.0 another
idea is it could turn out that we
ourselves might be in simulated
artificial reality so that our reality
is reality 2.0 now the only trouble is
is a fatal floor with this title which
has probably occurred to all of your
listeners already which is you know re
reality 2.0 suggests the people AOL
1990s You've Got
Mail it's it's so retro that it sounds
like it's a step it's a step backwards
rather than a step forwards was it yeah
even our colleague Max tmar went to life
3.0 to avoid this Pro reality 4.0 maybe
not but someone had the great idea of
yeah well reality plus because although
putting a plus uh on the uh on the end
of a title maybe becoming a ubiquitous
cliche too at least in uh at least in
streaming services you know Disney dis
plus Apple TV plus Paramount plus and so
on at least it's a 2020s cliche and not
a and not a 1990s cliche and it kind of
suggests this idea of there's more to
reality than you think there's physical
reality there's virtual reality there's
simulated realities and yeah if in the
future somebody comes up with a reality
streaming service where you're able to
choose between the virtual realities and
you want to live in then reality plus
might be a might be an appropriate name
for it so in the end I thought okay got
to go with reality plus got to go with
the plus sign and that gives a a hint at
the enhancement that we're going to be
uh experiencing in the maybe
augmentation and supplementation but
maybe even full scale replacement of our
Notions of reality and I've had on as I
said Don Hoffman said believes reality
does not exist and it's sort of a an
avatar uh scenario a desktop scenario uh
which is which is provocative and you
refer to him towards the end of the book
um we maybe get a chance to get into
that uh I neglected to mention that you
are the co-director of nyu's Center for
mind and Brian Consciousness so I oh no
brain Consciousness you know my mom
named me you know Brian so that people
would make that mistake and it happens
about two times a day um and you were
elected a fellow of both the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences but in your
native land down under of Australia you
were elected the Australian Academy of
humanities as well and I want to start
by
uh because they can't resist it's like
if if we were to hear go to a concert by
your Countryman ACDC and they don't play
You Shook Me All Night Long there's just
you know you're GNA leave unsatisfied I
have to take it from the master I want
you to define the hard problem of
Consciousness yeah so the hard problem
of Consciousness is the problem of
explaining how physical processes in the
brain give rise to subjective experience
to the subjective experience of the mind
and the world so for me the core of
Consciousness that word means many
things to many people but the core of
Consciousness is subjective experience
of perceiving of feeling of thinking of
acting it's anything that feels like
something from the inside and the easy
problems of Consciousness and things
like explaining behaviors which are
associated how can we walk how can we
talk I get a stimulus I can point to it
I can act on it I can report it I can
say yeah there's a red object over there
we got a beat on how to explain those
things in terms of physical processes in
the brain specify a mechanism show how
it does the job but those were the easy
problems the hard problem is why is all
that accompanied by subjective
experience why doesn't it all go on in
the dark without any subjective
experience at all I mean it doesn't at
least in me I know that I'm conscious I
experience all this and I assume
it does for you as well but why does it
right now right now we don't know that's
the hard problem yeah and you refer to
work done um by Thomas Nagel and and
others and I want to write a book you
know my dream Dave maybe with your help
I want to write a book what is it like
to be Thomas Nagel uh and the author
would be a bat yeah because you know I
think a lot of these things you know to
physicists tend to be a little bit
unsatisfying in other words we um we
kind of really tie into the physical the
boltzman brain aspects we'll get into
that the it from bit and I think the
more interesting you know uh bit from it
uh but uh but you know how do we how do
we understand at a core grasp you know
and reconcile things that are kind of
this yeah sub subjective and I want to
maybe begin the the core conversation by
talking about this kind of maybe uh
fitful tension between physicists and uh
and philosophers so a famous quote by
Galileo when he invented not the
telescope but he perfected the Galilean
telescope here's an example of one um he
didn't invent it uh but he used it for
the first time astronomically and what
he said he did with it is resolve
questions that had vexed philosophers
for many generations and caused them
unending suffering in other words he was
kind of like pejoratively putting down
uh philosophers and nowadays we see it
in people like Lawrence Krauss and
others and talking about the utility or
lack thereof why is there a tension
between physics and philosophy and and
do philosophers have antipathy towards
uh those of my elk
physicist I don't think so and I don't
think there has to be attention here at
all I mean the great physicists of the
past many of them were great
philosophers you know Isaac Newton
considered himself a philosopher he was
professor of natural philos philosophy
but I mean along the way and when he was
born the problems of space and time were
problems for a philosopher now Newton
was a good enough philosopher that he
managed to make progress on this on this
problem with new methods formal methods
experimental methods that would
basically turn this problem of
philosophy into something we could make
progress on and thereby kind of birthed
the core of the science of physics and
this happens in philosophy all along um
so many times you know disciplines like
economics psychology
Linguistics uh parts of logic kind of
started as philosophy
some philosopher made progress on it and
then we okay then we spin off the
science okay so now what's happened is
that a number of these a lot of
philosophers have been successful enough
that we now have the the successful
spin-off going in physics in Psychology
in linguistics and so on and what's left
in philosophy almost by nature is the to
hard basket the stuff that we haven't
figured out how to turn into a science
yet but on the other hand there's quite
a lot of things which are just to the
interface and I would like to think this
science of Consciousness is precisely
one of those starting with a very core
philosophical question how could there
be Consciousness in a physical universe
and we're managing to uh to at least
bite bits and pieces of it off so we now
have a thriving science of Consciousness
that involves neuroscientists
psychologists and also philosophers
right around right around that that
borderline then there are still bits of
the science of of the study of
Consciousness which were in the
philosophy camp but bits
in the science camp and actually my
experience is I've had a lot of of great
experience interacting with
neuroscientists psychologists right now
I've got a big project with a number of
neuroscientists where we're trying to
design experiments to test some of the
leading philosophical theories of
Consciousness and come up with uh with
experiments that will that will do that
so yeah historically look at all the
physicists who were great philosophers
Heisenberg shinger bore Einstein early
first half of the 20th century they were
all great philosophers one thing that
happens over time is that things get a
bit more professionalized maybe you know
physicists have to focus a little bit
more these days and some philosophers
focus a bit more so there's less room
for for maybe there's a bit less of that
kind of crossover but still there's so
many physicists who are who are uh
brilliant philosophers too you know John
Wheeler was a brilliant philosopher look
now someone like Max techmar wrote you
know the mathematical universe that's a
great work of philosophy people like
David deuts who are at the interface
between the two uh philosophers like
David Albert and Tim mlin who know who
know physics forward and backwards so I
still think there's a real productive
core there yeah I would agree and I mean
if they look at the root of the words
meaning you know love of wisdom love of
knowledge I think that's uh that's
something that physicist should aspire
to of course yeah as you say we have to
focus we have to Niche down we have to
choose a you know a profession and so
forth so typically those questions I
call them the 3: a.m dorm room couch
questions you know those kind of
dissipate as we mature and then people
look back with somewhat of disdain you
know or just like oh you know David the
first exposure I had in college to
philosophy was you know philosophy 101
my first day of freshman year at Case
Western Reserve University and then the
uh Professor was this guy who looked
like you know the guy the professor in
Welcome Back Cotter uh his name I think
was even Cotter or something like that
and uh he' never T before and we would
just have these you know INF itely long
exams uh on on a quarter you know on a
on a b monthly basis and they were all
true false it was like you know the the
categorical imperative is something that
can subsume the ontological is true I
don't know and I would get less than a
50% on each qu I don't understand how
that's possible it was only it was only
5050 Choice my thumb's rather occupied
right now holding up good old Carl Sean
but yours is free to push that like
button and don't forget to subscribe it
really helps us with the algorithm now
back to the episode but to recapitulate
one thing you said is that I mean some
of these things are coming back and
really providing a sound basis for
physics research in other words they're
encountering aspects of the Multiverse
of alien worlds in this in this book
certainly of the substrate dependence or
lack thereof all topics we're going to
get into and I want to start with this
uh kind of uh really amusing section of
the book where you you go through kind
of what I call uh the I'm going to call
I'm going to hope this Trends but I'm
going to called the Chalmer equation and
it's kind of the Drake equation but for
the probability of of simulation to
exist in Virtual Worlds to exist and you
go through all the different kind of
steps in exactly the way that Frank
Drake 60 years ago this year came up
with his eponymous Drake Equation which
is to settle on the number of you know
alien uh civilizations that could
potentially have extraterrestrial
intelligence um and of course that's
still an open question you know Paul
Davies who was on the show recently
wrote a book called the Eerie silence
you know the fmy Paradox why don't we
see them um I wondered was that kind of
an inspiration for the you know you
don't call it the chmer equation but
it's sort of of the same vein is it
not yeah it is kind of a similar
statistical equation here I guess I'm
thinking about the number of simulations
I should say that here I got a lot of
inspiration from the philosopher Nick
Bostrom who's thought about the
simulation himself and he comes up with
his own equation for uh what fraction of
beings in the universe we should expect
will be simulated and uh he ties it to
some complicated things like the number
of beings who become posthuman and so on
I don't fully agree with with how Ostrom
does it which is why I come up with with
my own way of of coming at it but the
but the equation takes a fairly similar
form first we need to take the
probability there's this background
assumption which is you know the
question is if you had to simulate how
many universes how how many beings how
many simulated beings are going to have
Consciousness just like mine in the
history of the Universe um well one
assumption there is that simulated
beings can be conscious at all I don't
know How likely is that not everyone is
going to to ground that but I say okay
let's grant that I think it's at least
50% probability that uh simulated beings
can be conscious at all put your own U
put your own probability there then
conditional on simulated conscious
beings being possible what I call
simulated humanlike conscious beings
being possible beings with experience
like us what is the probability that
there will be many of them that they
will greatly
outnumber humans and well again that
depends on some assumptions it depends
on beings getting to the point where
they can have the capacity to build
these beings and that they will choose
to build them I say okay well let's give
that at least whatever whatever
probability you get for that I say let's
give it at least 50% multiply those out
you then get a 25% chance that most
beings with conscious experiences like
mine are themselves simulated beings and
then
running running the pro probabilities a
little bit further you basically get
just under 25% chance that I'm in I'm
myself in a simulation so I okay that's
a that's just a back of the envelope
case but it's the back of the envelope
case for 25% chance we in a simulation
if you wanted to be more conern
conservative you could dial some of
those back to one in 10 and and you
still get a one in 100 chance and that's
at least interesting yeah as I always
say though I gave a talk on you know
maybe enemy territory I spoke at the SEI
Institute six years ago now maybe and I
laid out a case for you know my my
complaints against the Drake equation
and this is at The Institute that Frank
Drake and Jill tart you know built so I
had to tread kind of carefully but I
said you know to scientists like like
myself the number is is interesting but
but the error bars are much more
important because the error bars subsume
all your ignorance all your
uncertainties all the model dependencies
all the calibration biases etc etc and I
went through an example where I
calculated let's do the Drake equation
for how many people are in the World
Famous San Diego Zoo down the road for
me at this very moment I go through the
calculation people can see it on YouTube
at CI institute's website YouTube
channel and I come up with a number and
I come up with a number of people there
it's like 8,000 but the uncertainty was
plus or minus 12,000
there could be negative people there
could be holes and virtual people you
know and and kind of suffusing the Void
there uh so the point being that the
error bars are you know in some cases
more important than that number itself
so what would you ascribe the error bar
on either the 25% or the 100% or the 1%
um you know some people say it's even
much higher uh than than either one of
those two numbers you know the 25% so
talk about the errors in that
calculation which is what really matters
to scientists in the end yeah and in
fact in this case the error bars in a
way play in my favor because the
conclusion I want to argue for here is
that we don't know that we're not in a
simulation that we can't rule it out so
to the extent that there's a whole lot
of uncertainty here well that just
increases the likelihood that yeah we
don't know there are possibilities here
we can't exclude but I agree that
there's all kinds of uncertainty here
one one source of uncertainty is just on
the the Consciousness side right we
don't understand Consciousness so we
don't know whether simulated being could
be conscious at all I go 50/50 but
someone might say come on why I believe
that maybe that's a maybe that's that's
under 10% another source of uncertainty
is whether simulated universes will be
possible will the laws of physics
ultimately be be computational of course
Roger Penrose thinks that the laws of
physics are not computable so we'll
never have a simulation of the universe
at least on a classical computer I mean
at this point I'd like to think that
even if a classical computer can't do it
can't do it just say you know Penrose is
right that the true theory of quantum
gravity will have some non-computable
element in it I'd like to think that
whatever that element is we could then
you know we could then capture that
element and use that to build new
computers quantum gravity computers that
would thereby exploit this this
non-computable element and we get
universe simulations that way but okay
there's a big source of uncertainty
there and the third is less is maybe
tied to the sociology tied to the future
is it the case that we will actually
have beings even though these
simulations could exist is it the case
we'll get to the point where we have
beings who can build them and do build
them maybe all the beings of the future
will
be will be uh self-protective enough
maybe that they choose npn to create
Advanced General artificial general
intelligence thinking that this is just
too dangerous or maybe they'll be
ethical enough to say man we can't
create these simul universes that would
be playing God so yeah maybe this
sociological part is probably the most
uncertain of them all I mean I'm just
thinking that the naively these
populations will be gho someone's going
to do it eventually it's going to be
useful for all these purposes help
predict the future help understand the
world scientists love to run simulations
now so much science is simulation based
once we can simulate the whole universe
of course scientists are going to want
to run some Universe simulations to see
what happen but who knows maybe maybe
the the institutional review boards come
in with will be cut off they only get a
very good not an excellent you know from
the galactic Science Foundation right um
but in the case of the Drake equation
what a lot of people point to is
successive things like the Kepler
Mission and calculating the number and
observing actually real data unlike um
you know some some branches of of uh
really theoretical physics um like
string theory or whatever where where
very little data actually exists and
it's all retrodictive and not predictive
but but in any case I'm not going to go
off on a pmic about String Theory right
now uh but on the other hand we've
reduced some of these terms in the uh in
the Drake equation to basically what I
call the only thing that's remaining are
the sociological terms and the lifetime
um you go through this really and it's
just such a great book I I can't
recommend it highly enough especially
for my fellow physicists and those nerds
uh like me out there because Dave goes
through in great detail but it's so
entertaining this notion of well what is
the brain viewed as a supercomputer and
you know we had this notion uh that the
brain human brain is so far surpassing
it's got more neurons and connections
between neurons than there are G you
know galaxies in the observable universe
etc etc um and yet you make a very uh
convincing uh calculation that the human
brain is sort of equivalent to a 10 peda
flop computer right now and there are
computers that we use to analyze data
from the universe the cosmic microwave
background owned by the department of
energy that are 10 pedop flop computers
you know you know that scale and that's
what 60 years after general you know
Turing machines were kind of first
conjectured by Alan Turing and and and
so forth by noyman and others so in such
a short amount of time we're already
surpassing in raw computation power uh
and that's one of the terms I think that
would have to go into a Chalmer equation
for calculating the number of simul so
what other things remain as I said the
sociological term the lifetime of
intelligent civilizations before they
blow themselves apart create some
runaway AI uh create some virus or
whatever those that's the limiting
factor in our understanding and the
maximum contributor to our error bars
what is in the chers equation again you
don't call it that but I can call it
that uh what is what is the the limiting
factor and what have we learned most um
most recently you know from analoges of
you know Consciousness keplers or so
forth like what are the current
experimental and theoretical computer
science or sociological um terms that
have Shrunk the error bars in that
equation that's interesting um yeah I
guess on the uh the first Factor there's
like is simulated Consciousness possible
as simulated physics possible and the
limiting factors there are going to be
tied to our knowledge of Consciousness
and of physics on the sociological side
there's going to be um will we get to
the point where we can make these and
will we choose to uh to make them but
maybe yeah the technology side is
interesting I mean yeah ex the exact
number of pedop flops required to
simulate a brain or a universe I mean in
certain respects you might say the
simulation argument doesn't need overly
strong arguments here just say it's a
vast amount that's required course we
don't need to hypothesize that the
Universe in which a simulation is run is
the same as ours you it seems actually
very likely it might be quite different
um might be quite different from ours
and I mean obviously if the universe is
finite there's pretty good reason to
think no universe no finite Universe can
run a perfect simulation of itself but
you must oh some people say ah therefore
the simulation hypothesis is bunk but of
course the relevant hypothesis is that
complex universes can run simulations of
simpler universes or parts of themselves
and so on we also should hold open the
possibility that the simulating universe
is
infinite it's quite different laws of
physics from ours perhaps and that is
somehow trivial in these infinite
universes with infinite resources to uh
to create univers with even with with
finite resources such as such as our own
appears to be at least in the known
universe um so from that perspective
it's like even if those resource bounds
don't hold then all we need to do is
move to say for example the infinite
simulation hypothesis and we should
still give some probability to that but
it is interesting that actually
simulation technology has been moving
along very very fast in recent years
both on the you know people actually
build Cosmic simulation and uh and yeah
every every few years the cosmic
simulations get a whole lot more get a
whole lot more detailed and more fine
grained and yeah they multiscale
simulations are becoming more and
more more and more of a thing and then
from the bottom up it's like well
virtual reality technology is also
developing for me that's it's very
relevant that actually we now have these
simulations that we can enter and
experience immersively those are not yet
VR is not yet a copy of the physical
world but if VR just gets better and
better for 50 years or 100 years we'll
probably have the version of VR which is
indistinguishable from the physical
world once we have that technology in
front of us we will actually be able to
put people into simulations that feel
like they're simulations of physical
reality at that point no one's going to
be able to say hey this is just way out
this is science fiction we're actually
going to have the technology in front of
us it'll be happening to some people and
we can then raise the question maybe
just that is happening to us now some
people say oh isn't the simulation
hypothesis meaningless because it's
unverifiable or undetectable once we can
actually put people into these
simulations no one can say it's
meaningless anymore it's like we've got
it right here I've got it right here so
I'm gonna now strap on my my Oculus you
have one there too Dave we can uh we can
enter into VR you did a VR interview
with Cassandra here in uh e San Diego
for the Arthur C Clark Center and Arthur
C Clark makes an in the in your book as
well one of his books of childhood end I
believe you you quote from which preag
this oce of VR and and uh and and
computer simulation and so forth uh but
now this isn't super realistic you know
when um when I put these on in fact I've
tried to use it for you know to to do
exercise and then you get all these
cookies and I tried to use it for
meditation and it's like blindingly
bright I'm taking you have a more recent
uh version than I do mine is the Oculus
ocul go I think from three years ago
which is totally outdated you have the
quest yeah I mean they're
fun know there's there's the a
fundamental problem with them and that
you know that you're wearing this giant
thing and as we know now I don't know if
you've checked you know your your IRA or
or whatever but you know Facebook which
is now known as meta you know for the
metaverse is is cratering and and going
you know going down which is making a
lot of people really happy
uh but uh that's sort of a virtual where
you could put this on you could talk to
your Facebook friends maybe but it's
it's so cumbersome and even if you use
your voice it's kind of cumbersome now I
mentioned Galileo before turns out
Galileo may have been the first person
to invent a VR or maybe an AR headset uh
because he there was the problem of
computing time as you know in the in the
16 and 1700s and there was this
longitude prize that was offered for the
first kind of reliable clock and Galileo
said well hey wait a second I've got
this telescope and I can see the moons
of Jupiter and they're as periodic as
you would like them to be and in fact
you can see them you know all over the
Earth and so he invented this helmet
with two telescope or one telescope
attached called like a chronoscope or
something like that and he used it to
you know trying to claim the longitude
price uh and of course it was rejected
because people oh you can only see the
moons you know nine months out of the
year and what do you do those other
months he's like well you could you know
calculate tables and interpolate but um
but you know back then if you look at
well how much has really change in
augmented reality now I could you know
go to Ikea's website I can take a
picture of my you know carpet and
that'll suggest it how chair will look
um it's kind of being used as Facebook's
using it for like advertising and I
wonder when we scale up these digital
computers as I understand it Mo's law
starts to uh deteriorate because as the
power of the computer grows and it does
grow at this exponential rate the number
of use cases the number of users and the
demands that they're putting on it are
always scratching you know the upper
bound of the envelope so you in other
words you're you're almost like the the
utility of them becomes so much higher
in addition to their raw power and it
and it's growing at a rate that's you
know sort of causing their bounds to
saturate when it comes to the actual
number of say output and you could
distill that into any ter know not just
pedop flops but into how many papers get
ridden how many you know full
simulations come to conclusion and those
are actually tapering off for these
large supercomputers and so we have to
keep building more and more so that the
plateau gets higher and higher can you
see that as a term in the Chalmer
equation that would eventually limit the
uh you know kind of optimistic prospects
of a you know World in which we are
already living in such a simulation
especially if we're talking about yeah
building ultimate full simulations of
the human brain full ground level
simulations of physics um yeah in the
book I give some calculations that requ
that rely on something like Moes law
continuing so yeah every decade we get
this multiplication factor and given
that it's not too hard to say okay I'm a
philosopher I take the Long View I don't
care what happens in the next 10 years I
care what happens what happens
eventually if it's 100 years 200 years
I'm fine as long as it continues but
yeah is it if it asmp tootes at some
point then obviously there are serious
uh there are serious potential
limitations there I mean I kind of hope
then at a certain point we get to
harness the power of the Sun and do
amazing things we U things that we
couldn't do before but um yeah if it
turns out there are principled limits
then I mean you know we know there
current physics has principled limits
like the speed of light and the plank
scale and so on so either we eventually
if we eventually hit them then I think
we need to get more creative on the uh
on the software side so to speak if we
hit ultimate Hardware limitations then
we do things on the on the software side
for example we find speedups and
shortcuts in our simulation as people do
already maybe people will find ways
where okay we're only going to simulate
local parts of the universe okay
simulating the whole universe Out Of
Reach let's just simulate the solar
system in detail and everything else is
just kind of a sketchy background copy
it'll obey a few basic principles of
cosmology and not too much hey that
could have been what messed up those
experiments years ago right exactly in
addition to the dust that you talk about
at the end of the book we'll get into
that um so you mentioned you know so
Roger Penrose is three or four time
guest on uh into the impossible and yeah
you're right he does talk about the
limits of computability and his apocal
book The Emperor's New mind which was
the first science book I ever read and
it was kind of a treat to have him
endorse my first book uh way back when
before he won a Nobel Prize uh and uh
and and it's quite interesting and he
and I have talked and others have talked
about this notion of AI physicist so you
know what is the limitation of and our
friend Max tegmark who's also a guest
and friend um you know he is very s
about AI Fineman AI Galileo AI but I I
always remind folks I say you know what
um I don't know if you're familiar with
this Dave but um Einstein called the
happiest thought of his life and I've
got a little Einstein a virtual Einstein
here he is my gu my uh audience always
loves when I break out the the virtual
uh areas so yeah I only have one of
these that has uh actually been on the
show and that's Nome Chomsky uh but
maybe someday there'll be a Cher's
finger puppet from the unemployed
philosophers Guild this is this is this
is called the unemployed philosophers
Guild yeah who knew that Einstein was a
unemploy so Einstein was speaking about
uh the equivalence principle which
undergirds all of general relativity and
he said um he described what he called
the happiest thought of his life and
that was that an observer you know
freely falling in space would experience
no gravitational field meaning that you
know gravity and acceleration are you
know one and the same and that geodesics
or manifestations of the shortest paths
in a curvature free SpaceTime and there
when you add in curvature due to
gravitating mass then it changes and
Alters the perception of both spatial
intervals and time but um I posit to you
that I don't believe it's possible for
an AI G Einstein to exist because I mean
first of all how do you how do you uh
visualize the notion of of Freefall as a
silicon-based uh entity and then two
what does it mean to be happy like what
what what does an an AI mean when when
or she or it or Z or whatever feels
happy so isn't that you know kind of a a
counter you know proof that we could
ever come up with the a computer you
know simulator could come up with such
laws that the human brain has done over
and over again I think the human brain
is a big complex machine it's an amazing
machine it's a creative machine but it's
still made up of these neurons which are
appear to be computational units hooked
up in amazing ways that can learn in
amazing ways the imag
as far as we can tell is itself a kind
of simulation when we imagine things
when Einstein was imagining things and
Free Fall he was running a kind of
simulation himself running on this
incredible this incredible computer
Which is far more sophisticated than any
computer that we ourselves have
developed to date but you know AI is
moving fast I can't believe where it is
now compared to where it was 10 years
ago I did my PhD in an AI lab in the
1990s with with dark hopstad and back
then people used to say a year spent
working in AI a year spent working in AI
is enough to make you believe in God
because AI is so hard it's so hard to
get machines to do human level
sophisticated things but suddenly in the
last 10 years yeah machines doing image
recognition they're doing speech
generation they're doing game playing
they're doing navigation they're writing
their own code they're suddenly all
these hurdles are uh hurdles are falling
and yeah I mean we don't we don't
remotely have an AI Einstein yet but I'm
not going to be the one who bets against
it in 20 or 30 years time and yeah we do
have emotion is certainly a limiting
factor and AI right now but we do have
computational models of emotion at least
treating happiness and sadness as forms
of violence and I don't think anyone
would claim that we yet have ai systems
that experience genu and emotion but I
don't see the principal limit towards AI
ultimately there are what they call
Effective computing as a field and
people are working on this um machines
can be made to behave in certain ways
which at least seem to reflect
irritation satisfaction frustration
course big question are they really
experiencing it well that's a question
about Consciousness myate father used to
say well if you want to simulate you
know Pleasure and Pain response which is
you know some psychologists and social
philosop phers claim that's you know all
we're responding to as as conscious
entities uh he used to my father used to
say well just like when it does
something wrong you know you blow a
transistor you you know you you know
collapse a wave function if it's a
Quantum you know do something that is a
painful you know cost function for that
computer it's still not clear how to you
know simulate you know happiness and and
freef fall is it really the the sum
totality of of only pleasure with no
pain I mean obviously we can have super
positions you know right now I'm really
happy but I could be you know unhappy
very easily and I could be much happier
very easily too so it's not is it clear
that I have to be in the ultimate state
of Happiness to experience it you
mentioned God you mentioned you know
believing in God is kind of an off offut
but I do feel like you know it's pretty
remarkable that these you know Bronze
Age you know itinerant Semitic Wanderers
you know 3,000 years ago uh you know
came up with a a notion of you know
pleasure pain experience reality Free
Will Commandments moral and ethical
imperatives you know 3,000 years ago
were they creating uh the you know the
earliest version of The Sim hypothesis I
don't know how how far back some of
these simulation ideas go but you can
find elements of it ancient Chinese
philosophy Danga and his butterfly how
do I know I'm not a butterfly dreaming
that he's danger that that is where by
the way that's where the butterfly on
the on the cover came from that is meant
to be a virtual reality version of
Danger's butterfly
I could be I could be a butterfly
dreaming his his dang you find an Indian
philosophy ideas about um ideas about
illusion so many um the Hindu tradition
has God's mind supporting all of reality
and maybe this also connects to what you
find in the uh in the abrahamic
Traditions um where yeah
basically um God is so all powerful God
supports uh God supports reality and of
course the question is how did God
create reality I guess I I always
remember let there be light and there
was and there was light in the book I I
uh I speculated better about maybe what
actually went on was Let There Be
bits and yeah God creates some God
creates some bits the difference no
actually exactly so so in the Hebrew TR
the talmudic tradition that I'm more
familiar with um the what God does in
the first six days of creation is
separate so the second line after let
there be light or information however
you want to say it is uh in the world
was chaos and void and he created order
so in other words there's chaos which
could be a state like a one and there's
order which would be lower entropy could
be a zero and and he separates between
man and animal between vegetation water
and land uh and so it's not at all a
stretch uh to to hypothe hypothesize
that that is yeah there you go yeah show
that that's I got a great illustration
of this in the uh in the book on one
side we have there is a traditional God
creat creating the universe by creating
some bits and then the uh the tables and
chairs and animals and everything else
come from there on the on the other side
we have a simulator uh a simulator God
who here is like a teenage girl in the
next Universe up she's creating Reality
by programming her computer to create
bits that that create the trees and
dolphins and
iated I believe you only need zeros and
ones and and you talk about um a li Nets
who also you came up with the Primitive
Boolean Construction so yeah you only
need these you know fundamental units
Chaos and Order if you like um and so
it's not altogether um you know
impossible even to be in you know some
sort of resonance with a traditional
religious um you know conception and and
so I saw a funny thing in one of these
like onion type magazines it was like
you know scientists praise God for
creating an ultra realistic metaverse
that he calls the
universe but um I want to ask you
there's a very very provocative uh mle
middle section of the book where you
start talking you basically make the
claim that a Creator plus it from bit
equals a simulation and yet you still
personally don't believe that such a God
is worthy of worship nor do you worship
an orinary abrahamic or other Faith
Creator um you also don't believe that
is necessary or worthy of worship
potentially so but before we go there
Dave I want to ask you um what is it
from bit and why is it so Central it's
wheeler ISM uh like many things um but
uh how do you instantiate you know a
computer program um from the absence of
a computer program I've had on and I'll
ask you to kind of um Steelman my oppon
maybe your opponent's ideas but if
you're if you're game but you know I've
had on intelligent designers I've had on
people that believe in God believe in uh
you know creation and and even people
like Mitch yaku is your you know fellow
New York Professor down there somewhere
in New York City but this no that um
that there's nothing we've ever
discovered that can't be traced in some
way to something with a design uh that
contains information and in other words
there's life and you could say well life
didn't come but something that has an
information content a bit that is not
associated with a a the you know a mind
in some sense a computer program written
by itself doesn't exist a hieroglyphic
on a cave doesn't exist without a person
but first despite that long Preamble
what is it from bit and then we'll get
into the creation aspects of it yeah
well it fromit as this slogan from the
physicist John Wheeler who basically
said maybe you know at the fundamental
level of reality what there is is the
difference between two different answers
to a question yes or no one or zero and
Wheeler took this in a certain direction
towards the participatory Universe where
observation plays a central role that
kind of gets you into the role of the
mind and the foundations of physics but
the direction that I want to take in
which a lot of people want to take it
it's just the idea that at the bottom
level of physics there could be
something digital like uh ones and zeros
binary States we have this wonderful
example of this that so many people know
which is John Conway's Game of Life
which is a cellular automatan it's
basically a two-dimensional Universe
with a whole bunch of cells Each of
which can be in one of two states they
can be on they can be off and we've got
these very simple rules that you know a
cell turns on if three of its neighbors
are on then it turns off if uh if there
are too few or too many neighbors and
from those basic laws of binary physics
of digital physics we can generate all
kinds of behavior and from this you know
many people have speculated that okay
there's so many forms digital physics
could take maybe even our world has a
level of digital physics underneath
standard physics now my my sense of this
is that most physicist don't take this
terribly seriously as a as a working
hypothesis it goes Way Beyond any
evidence we have now there are people
like Steven wolam who are developing
ideas in the vicinity but I don't need
it to be true I just need it to be kind
of a
coherent a coherent hypothesis most
importantly you know these digital
worlds they're not worlds where nothing
is real they're not worlds where things
are an illusion there are worlds where
things are ultimately digital which is
important for me because it means at the
very least that just because something
is digital doesn't mean we should say it
isn't real a big central theme in this
book is that digital objects can be real
too and if we're in a simulation so if
so one thing I want to say is if we're
in a simulation we shouldn't say the
objects around us aren't real rather we
should say they're digital which is to
say you know if we're in a simulation
we've got tables we've got chairs we've
got molecules atoms quarks underneath
them and underneath those we have bits
this is to say that if we're in a
simulation Universe we're really in a
kind of it from bit Universe with some
digital Level under underlying all these
analog levels that we experience bits
underneath physics so that's how the
that's the it from bit idea and how it
connects to the simulation idea and then
yeah the next question of course is how
it connects to the creation idea right
so in the book you say creation plus it
from bit equals the simulation
hypothesis so where does that uh how can
we uh reconcile that that statement
equation so to speak yeah it's
interesting I was always a bit skeptical
about uh about creators and creation
most of my life I've considered myself
an atheist not particularly religious
don't believe in a God the whole god
idea seems somewhat Supernatural to me
but once you start thinking about
simulations and the simulation
hypothesis suddenly there's a root to
thinking about gods or at least creators
that no longer seems so Supernatural
just an entirely natural way of thinking
about God just as the creator of a
simulation you know we can create
simulations in our own world now without
needing any Supernatural powers of au
thought or maybe somebody in some
universe created this
universe as a simulation if you have a
simulation and it looks like you need a
simulator you need some kind of agent to
to create it and then that simulators
well I don't want to call the simulator
of God or a God but Simulator the
simulator has at least some of the
traditional properties of a god they
created this world presumably they can
affect all kinds of things they're
potentially all knowing about this world
those are three of the central
properties of a traditional good
traditional God now there are some other
properties the simulator might not have
being all good or all wise no particular
reason to think the simulator has to be
especially good or especially
wise um maybe they didn't create the
entire Cosmos either they created this
bit of the cosmos in some ways that's
more like what's sometimes called a
demiurge in some religious tradition
it's like a sub good that created at
least this part of reality for us they
fashioned it as a a kind of uh as a kind
of constructive Creator so most
importantly I would not recommend that
we that we erect a religion around the
simulator I don't think this being is
somebody we should worship I don't think
we should expect this being to have any
special moral Insight so for reasons
like that I'm uncomfortable describing
the simulator even if I believed we were
in a simulation I'd be uncomfortable
describing the simulator as a God but
nevertheless you it's a way of getting
some of the properties of a traditional
God and yeah and it combines with an it
from bit idea because after all how does
the simulator set up the simulation by
arranging a computer program by
arranging the bits so what I want to say
is if we're in a simulation then yeah
the it from bit hypothesis is true it's
all made of bits and all that was put
there by a simulator by a Creator so
basically the simulation hypothesis
equals the it from bit hypothesis plus
the creation hypothesis yeah we can call
that the charm equation pretty pretty
simple uh I like it the elegance and
simplicity um so to push back with a
little respect uh as you know I have for
you um if you think about you know uh a
God as being worthy of worship what
would it take for such a simulator or
abrahamic deity in other words what
would it take for you personally to find
such an entity worthy or is there no
combination of traits properties
behaviors that would make any simulated
or actual God worthy of David charr's
respect or worship rather I would
greatly resp there are beings I would
greatly respect I would have awe for you
know whether it's a simulator or a non-
simulator someone who created the
universe and understood so many things
if they have knowledge and understanding
and power that goes far beyond ours I
would have the most enormous respect
admiration and awe but I don't think I
would worship them maybe I guess I just
don't really understand worship and why
it's ever appropriate this is an amazing
being that uh that I would find yeah
fully uh fully awesome but worshiping
them is like a special why would I
worship them is it like are they the
source of all moral truth I guess I
don't really see why that would be true
i' it's a bit like my attitude to God be
like my attitude to Einstein but squared
Cub to the million power has to be
something of benevolence and there's
often times you know there is no
commandment uh in the Hebrew Bible which
is the root of the Christian Bible
obviously you know that uh there's no
commandment to to worship God there's no
commandment to believe in God there's a
commandment to love God and I always say
you know you don't get commanded to do
things that are natural like I don't
have to command you you know Dave to to
eat whatever kind of burger vegan or
meat that you like because you like to
do it it's fun right it's it tastes good
or for people that have children I don't
have to be commanded to love my kid kids
it's totally natural the other hand you
have to be commanded to love something
that's inherently unlovable so in the in
the biblical tradition God recognizes
that he is not lovable that he is there
are things about what he's doing and
there is Authority that by its nature is
not you know as anathema to some aspects
of creatures such as we who have free
will and I think that is the Divine
thing that we are ounded with free will
unlike animals we're the only creatures
that are mentioned Creations that are
mentioned that know good from evil know
life from Death know that we will die in
fact that's what you know Homo Sapien
really is referring to so I think
worship is the wrong word and I think
it's a that's that's like the
translation the the um you know the
sixth commandment most people say thou
shalt not kill right I mean you might
you might have been familiar with it's
not Thou shalt not kill of course there
God does a lot of killing we're
instructed to kill all sorts of people
but Thou shalt not murder which is
stealing of a life so there's a lot of
King James translations one of them is
worship and I think the real term should
be awe and it's sort of you know in the
way I have conceived of it as coming
later in life back to Judaism which was
my roots is that God should be
visualized kind of like a parent a
father you know unlike the graduate
student girl that's the pro the hero of
your book uh the god goddess of your
book but um but it's it's sort of like
your father something a paternalistic
figure uh that is worthy of awe but a
little bit of fear so it's like your
father's the king and uh and you're
close to him and he cares about you and
it is a personal God which I have issues
with you know just believing in the
Supernatural suspension of all the laws
of physics for Brian keading but there's
a something one of my rabbis once said
he's like you know well if you were God
I'll ask you Dave you know but he said
you know if you were God what would you
be doing and and I asked him I don't
know I said what would you be doing he
said he said the exact same thing that's
happening right now you think I know
more than God you know it's like things
are are are behaving in a certain way
and for us you know it's a little bit of
of hubris and you don't have to respond
to this if you don't want to but but the
notion that you know we should believe
in God like oh wait God's waiting for
Brian keading or David Chalmer you know
if he exists if it exists you know he
really no it's it's more does God you
know Believe in Us so to speak are we
acting in accord with accordance with
those principles that will create
flourishing or minimize harm and CRS the
greatest amount of pleasure so I think
that's the more term the word in Hebrew
is caved it means to respect or make
heavy and that's also what you must do
it to your parents so you can respond if
you like I I don't you know we don't
need to continue on this main though I
have attitudes of respect and awe to
many human beings I've got respect and
awe for Einstein I've got respect and
awe for you know Nelson Mandela respect
all for Beyonce it's like in in in very
different ways um and it's like totally
if if I believed that there was this God
who created the universe and showed
themselves to have amazing wisdom and
amazing power then I would have I would
have respect and awe for that being uh
something something not something short
of worship I mean and if how simulators
turn out to have those properties maybe
they're going to turn out to be super
intelligent AIS or something I could I'd
have respect and all for that as well
but if they start behaving like um you
know if they start raining down death
and destruction then I'm going to why
actually I got into this when um I
probably got into this idea when I came
across my 5-year-old nephew playing a
game like uh like Sim City and he would
he would show me he would build up these
worlds and these these cities and these
forests everything and then he said
now's the fun part he he sets them all
on fire kill those people they're gone
they're gone okay you that is kind of
curiously reminiscent of the Old
Testament God right yeah so I thought
yeah that's I'm thinking my God is Not
Gonna if I'm if I'm going to if I'm
going to have respect in all for a for a
God I hope that uh yeah they're going to
be they're going to be much more the way
that you were describing the God they're
not going to care whether we worship
them they're not going to uh they they
they're going to reain down death and
destruction but they're going to try and
set things up exactly there is there's a
lot of that and also I I often you know
point out to people they say oh you know
scientists should run the world you know
scientists embody you know the best
aspects of of humanity and you know
you're so childlike and and it's
wonderful to see something and I say
yeah you know scientists are like
children we're very inquisitive we're
very curious we're very you know kind of
um you know e egotistical in a certain
good way and we also don't play well
with others we don't share our toys with
others we compete like you know it's
like we're selfish we're jealous we're
Petty you know so it's like there's no
single I always say there's no
single-edged swords out there it's all
they're all double-edged swords so every
blessing comes with a curse and one of
the curses of of such a God is yeah is
that Temptation that involuntary
volitional or or otherwise you know like
what happens if I you know take away you
or put this little tiny virus out there
and we'll see what happens and we could
talk The Odyssey some other time but I
want to get back to the book um you know
when I'm reading the book I'm thinking
um let's say there is the simulation um
I know my AUD and we're going to take
audience questions I have stored up uh
from you know over a hundred uh
responses to you generously sharing your
time on the podcast uh but one thing
that you know they want to know and
they're screaming out to know is why um
and I know it's not a kosher scientific
question ask why but why would there why
would they simulate anything in other
words you know the talic rabbis of 2,000
years ago you know came to a conclusion
that God shouldn't have created the
world like it caused more problems than
than it so why why is there a simulation
why what is the is there you know is
there a theological purpose for such a
universe I don't know why do we create
simulations I me we create a lot of
simulations like simulated worlds now
already I guess right now there are
maybe two overarching purposes one is
entertainment you simulations of video
game worlds and so on there a vast
entertainment industry and the other one
is science uh people like running
scientists like running uh simulations
now to understand the the systems that
they're working with whether it's the uh
the cosmos or traffic patterns in a city
or a water flow everyone is doing
science with simulations it's easy to
imagine the both reasons could be
reasons why people might eventually
create simulated universes do science
run the simulation many times pick up
the statistics see how often life
develops hey you want to study that
those Drake equations issues let's see
how often life actually develops given
certain laws of physics and how often
intelligence develops and so on so
that's One Good Reason yeah
entertainment is another or the third is
predicting the future you know we run
simulations to predict what will happen
whether it's say a military simulation
or a financial simulation or this or
that that episode of Black Mirror where
a couple there's an app that a couple
can run run a whole bunch of simulation
of their simulations of their
relationships to see if they're uh to
see if they're compatible actually it's
a sidebar on this is I've come to think
that using simulation technology for
predictive purposes is actually very
difficult especially for social
predictive purposes because do you
simulate the simulation technology or
not like do the people in that black
mirror episode when they run when they
go out on dates do simulations all the
way down Sim
right
yeah but if you do that then of course
you the simulations they're running
themselves going to have to have
simulations and you're going to
basically have an infinite regress the
alternative is that some point just
simulate worlds where they don't have
simulation technology that's going to be
totally unreliable two people could be
totally compatible in a world without
the technology but the technology will
ruin it for them and more generally I
think this is this is going to be a
regrowth for any any use any social uses
of simulation technology for predictive
it brings up a lot of of little can go
down maybe I'll I'll I'll start with one
you know there's the old joke you know
if you can um if you can uh simulate
being authentic then you've got it made
you know
like you know on the surface he's deep
but you know superficially he's very
shallow right um so you know deep down
each all the it from bit you know there
is a certain kernel of of um and as you
mentioned skepticism among the physics
Community likewise Steven Wolfram past
guest multiple guest on this show um
there's got this great skepticism in
other words there's just direct
criticism there's nothing that's
practically relevant to theories of
everything to unification uh there these
these things tend the cellular automata
tend to be really good at simulating the
properties of cellular automata just in
the same way that string theory is the
best theory ever invented to study the
properties of string theory uh in other
words it's it's very much siloed and I
wonder you know uh is that because of
this you know this this substrate
dependency versus you know you could get
get things irreducibly down to
information but again all instantiations
of computability even if you claim the
human brain is a computer it's still
running on a substrate um how do we get
the substrate and where does the
substrate come from or can you have a
truly substrate free and I don't want to
have any SP I hate when authors would or
podcasts would have me on their show and
say describe your entire book so my
audience doesn't have to buy no I'm not
going to do that but at the end of
reality plus you talk about the dust
cloud and and so forth and this
fundamental primitive computer but the
conclusion tends to
towards that well it can contain enough
bits you know and theoretically that it
could support a computational system of
you know not infinite complexity but
some limited but large complexity how do
you get the substrate Independence we
still need a substrate yeah well the
substrate could just be something like
like bits pure bits yeah I don't really
actually need the it from bit hypothesis
to make to make this idea R I think it
provides a very Vivid illustration
certainly I don't need like the bits to
be serious physics required for a
unification for a a ground unified
theory but it would be enough if we
could have say a grand unified theory
physics and then you know in the
simulation maybe the bits don't ever
actually show up in the equations
because you know when you run a I run a
simulation of Newtonian physics then if
it works well you'll just see Newtonian
physics you won't see the bits right
inated in Silicon or in a cub there
still is a
that has to exist to run the computer so
here we have two versions of the it from
bit idea one is what I call the pure it
from bit idea where the basic level is
bits and they're not you got zeros and
ones and there's nothing more basic yeah
the zeros and ones we all know about
they're made of something more basic
they're you know they're instantiated in
voltages on transistors within circuits
um so that so that was what we might
call the bit from it idea the bits the
bits that we actually have on our
computers going to underlying it and
that could be you could combine the it
from bit idea from it with that then you
get what I call the it from bit from it
idea objects in our world made of bits
but at the underlying level those bits
are made of something more basic maybe
for example there's a computer in the
next Universe up that's uh instantiating
those bits with some analog of voltages
in their world and that'll be it from
bit from it and then the substrate will
be the it and that will then we got to
ask the question are the its in that
world made of bits which are made of
further its and then we'll get it from
bit from it from bit from it and on you
uh and on your go but also one thing is
also worth saying is you don't actually
need classical bits to make this work
you can make this work with uh with Q
bits you know the kind of the kind of
the analog of bits you find in Quantum
Computing and I think you can also make
it work with um with continuous bits or
what I sometimes call Reals in the book
it actually doesn't have to be binary
physics it could be continuous physics
the key idea is just kind of a level of
information underneath everything which
could be binary information it could be
Quantum information or it could even be
a kind of continuous information it's
just I use bits because that's by far
the simplest version of this idea but
I'm not sure that binar per se is so
important but the issue you raise of is
there a substrate beneath the
information that's super important
because
um yeah I think there's two very
different ideas here and the world of
pure information it's a beautiful Vision
but it's yeah it's not totally clear I
agree in fact you know so I like to
Steelman my own arguments from time to
time so one of the things I point
because I'm a you know more in the
materialist that you do need a substrate
it's a fundamental issue even the cubits
are actual matter material particles Etc
and those and the forces and Fields that
interact between them um but I also will
push back on my own thinking and say
well you know the first operating system
by definition was written without an
operating system the you know Assembly
Language was written without Assembly
Language you know the first uh the first
modern you know editors are written word
processors written without word process
so um so there's proof but you know at
some level it is you know increasing the
Colora of complexity Etc goes up um and
and you do bootstrap recursively but you
know it's to me it's it's it's it's
difficult to Envision without some
fundamental layer of a substrate which
you know comes from physics and the the
issue that I think presents a serious
challenge that you you do address in the
book and and you partially alluded to it
now but um is the notion of what we
believe at least is non-computable like
so turing's original 19 you know 56 or
whatever paper 48 paper whatever
computable it was on computable numbers
and it was on numbers um that could be
uh programmed and actually executed by a
universal machine a generalized you know
Computing machine and that excluded
things like transcendental numbers or
irrational numbers and you just
mentioned continuous real numbers but of
course all the numbers are you know
include transcendental numbers uh and
the most two most important numbers seem
to be um you know numbers that computers
have a very difficult time with in other
words the number zero and the number
infinity if it's a number a pione yes no
I talk about that but I always say you
know the middle four digits of pi are my
PIN number so don't tell anyone on I can
lose a lot in my my University of
California savings account uh but uh but
yeah so those are yeah so they are
irrational numbers we can't we can't you
square root of two Etc there's no
program that can can calculate them for
for transcendental numbers and so they
fail the the ATT Turing type machine
cannot produce them but similarly
Infinity cannot be really uh represented
on a on a computer we can we can you
know approximate it to arbitrary
Precision uh but you know if you truly
do things that the human mind is totally
capable of finding you know the uh the
the logarithm of uh of negative Infinity
you know we could we can think about
those numbers and we can use those
numbers even to construct calculus but
how can a computer of any kind you know
capture this notion of infinity is that
something that's uniquely relevant to
this you Squishy wet supercomputer or do
you think that notion will exist even in
a simulated universe and therefore the
Continuum is true in other words
there'll be an infinite number of of
bits required to represent the actual
Universe yeah well we can maybe we can
yeah Infinity is tricky but we can
axiomatize Infinity we can kind of get
out grasp we can try to articulate our
grasp of infinity via axium and you in
traditional set theory there is this
axium of infinity which is a finite
string of symbols that we lay out
different level of INF express our
understanding of
infinity yeah of course what we find
actually is is that these axioms for
Infinity actually under determine its uh
its nature it's like how many levels of
infinity are there is the Continuum
hypothesis true or false is the one
after the integers the reals or is there
a whole bunch in between I mean you can
add axioms to try and uh to try and
determine these matters but then there's
always going to be stuff left
underdetermined for reasons in the
foundations of of mathematics so it may
be that we will never get a precise
grasp of infinity through a finite set
of axioms on the other hand who says
that humans have such a precise grasp of
infinity anyway maybe we can lay out
enough axioms that capture the elements
of our own understanding of infinity it
won't articulate everything but maybe it
will articulate everything in the human
conception infin
so again uh maybe we'll go back to Steel
Manning now I'm going to ask you to
Steel Man in part three of the book uh a
wonderful section uh you you end part
three by saying very carefully you say
say we can't know that we are not in a
simulation why did you phrase it like
that and what's the best argument
against that in other words against what
would you say to some what would you say
on behalf of somebody who says no we can
know that we are not in a simulation how
do they know what is the evidence
they'll presumably try and come up with
some evidence they say it's conclusive
evidence that we can't be in a
simulation the basic reason I think
that's impossible it looks like any
evidence could itself be simulated so if
the evidence can be simulated then we'll
never know for sure in principle we can
have simulations indistinguishable from
unsimulated reality so to defeat that
someone's going to need to come up with
something maybe you know maybe who's to
say like a Penrose style argument look
human beings can do things that no
classical computer could do I mean I'm
dubious about that but even if it were
true I'd think okay let's just move to
quantum computers or quantum gravity
computers and build our simulations
build our simulations like that I mean
maybe the biggest challenge is
consciousness could Consciousness be
simulated and many people say uh you're
crazy if you think a simulation could
have Consciousness I hav have thought
about this a fair amount and I don't see
any bar to uh Consciousness and
principle being had by simulated
creatures I would at least say that we
can't know that Consciousness can't be
simulated so maybe think of that that
also justifies this Nega negative way of
putting it I'm lowering the bar myself I
don't want to say we know we are in a
simulation because I think that's false
I don't think I know that for sure I
think there's some probability but we
might not be in a simulation so I want
to say but we my so the the most
important thesis for me is we might be
and when you when you translate we might
be into like epistemic Logic the not
logic of knowledge it just comes out as
not K not you can't know you're not in a
simulation
but English we might
be so I appreciate that it's I think
it's always important to uh toh describe
these things um so I want to uh turn in
the remaining uh 15 minutes if you can
spare another 15 minutes Dave okay great
um so I'm gonna ask you first would you
take the red pill it lets me out of the
Matrix it gives me access to all of
reality I think I would totally take the
red pill because it's going to enable me
to it's like you I grew up in Australia
and Australia was great but then I there
was this whole wide world out there and
I wanted to explore the whole wide world
if I grw up in The Matrix I think you my
view is the Matrix is real it's not like
it needn't be a dystopia it depends on
how it's run needn't be an illusion but
if I discover that I'm in reality and
out there is reality plus if I get the
opportunity to explore reality plus then
fantastic no I'm going to want to be
able to come back to the Matrix you know
all my f all my family all my friends
are going to be in the uh are going to
be in the matx Matrix I don't want to
lose touch with them entirely and for me
the Matrix will be part of reality but
in so far as the red pill represents
knowledge understanding exporation okay
next uh we have some questions from the
audience um so uh what do you think is
the ultimate and final machines that
human beings create this is from a man
by the name or a woman by the name of
high reality sensorium which I was going
to call my second child so what's the
Ultimate machine that humans Homo
sapiens could create well that's easy
the ultimate machines that hobos hobos
saens creates is the first machine which
is smarter than Homo sapiens after that
we will leave the creation after that we
will leave the creation to the Mach next
question
fromex if David CH thinks the delayed
Choice Quantum eraser experiment results
support the simulation hypothesis uh by
observing error correction codes in
process where the prior state of a
Quantum entangled Photon has changed to
match its entangled uh
counterpart so does the does the delayed
Choice Quantum arer results which are
not fully definitively support I suppose
um do you believe that that has any
bearing say on the uh support of the
simulation hypothesis yeah in general
I'm dubious I haven't really wored
worked carefully through those uh those
results in general um there are various
things in physics that people have
pointed to as potential supports for
simulation hypothesis whether it's Error
correcting codes possible glitches and
uh and approximations oh some people
think that you know the collapse of the
wave that the collapse of the wave
function might be potential support for
uh for the simulation hypothesis because
it shows like a a bit of rendering
efficiency okay well in in VR people
often say don't render the world until
you know for for the Observer until you
need to so some people say in quantum
mechanics we're we're going to yeah for
efficiency purposes we'll never collapse
the wave function until we need to but
as far as I can tell the world with um
yeah the world with an uncollapse wave
function is just as hard to simulate as
the one with a collapse wave function
and yeah world with a whole lot of error
correcting codes that's going to add to
the over next
question about a uh fellow philosopher
by the name of Bernardo castr castrop I
guess maybe um do you have any uh
thoughts or feelings on his work um
trying to eventually get him on the show
because he has the same initials as me
BK um so yeah em yeah what do you think
about his notion of analytic idealism
specific question this is a view with a
long tradition in philosophy many of the
ancient Indian philosophers were
idealists uh George Barkley uh in the uh
in the 17th 18th century was a was an
idealist in the 19th century everyone
was an idealist
Hegel Kant was the kind of idealist that
have got very unpopular for a long time
but lately it's had a bit of a comeback
and yeah in analytic philosophy in this
scientifically oriented philosophy a few
people are advocating the idea that
underneath the world might be a level of
uh of mind one way of getting there
actually is via the it from bit idea
then you say what are the bits made of
we need a substrate some people say ah
Consciousness it from bit from
Consciousness at the underlying level
reality is the interplay of
Consciousness there are some people the
pan psychist also put forward this idea
anyway
Bernardo um I don't understand his view
fully but he certainly has the idea that
underneath physics is a level of Mind
perhaps a single Cosmic mind this
corresponds to what sometimes called
Cosmo psychism it's like the whole
universe has a mind and we're just
aspects of that mind I take this view
it's extremely speculative and I think
it's got many big issues it needs to
address one big question is how does our
mind emerge from the cosmic mind or from
the bit mind no one's answered that
question yet but he I I view him as
someone who's doing really interesting
Som spective
Mets uh ask me is it true you told your
kids that if it is still not solved in
your lifetime you are to put quote still
hard on his Tombstone true or false I'm
hoping for I'm hoping that if not I
don't have kids but I'm hoping that
maybe uh maybe our AI successors will
one day solve the hard problem for us
it's like if it's too hard for it's too
hard for humans let's just program super
intelligent AIS to create ever more
intelligent super
hopefully
they'll graduate stud and by the way
what was Douglas hoffet like as a
graduate adviser oh boy he's amazing he
was full of you know full of ideas and
passions he was interested in everything
under the sun we'd have a workshop one
weekend on on humor another one on
creativity another one on analogy
another one on sexist language and so on
but he's also passionate about one thing
you don't quite get from his books his
books he's such an Enthusiast for so
many things in the in the real world
he's actually a dis Enthusiast for most
things he hates 90% of AI 90% of
philosophy 90% of of cognitive science
and that comes out also a little bit in
in person but the breadth of his
interest is amazing I love being in his
uh in his AI lab as a graduate student
so many smart other graduate students
around from psychology and AI
Ander work art on theer prize um just
quickly on the notion because I can't
resist like I asked you to you know if
you're ACDC to Play Back in Black I I
can't resist you asking you about popper
and and falsification as I claim it's
sort of a physicist version of girdle's
incompleteness theorem it's kind of the
best we have but it's not quite as
complete or good as as what girdle did
for mathematicians what do you make of
the uh of papism is it are we too uh
inured to the uh to the paparazzi as
Leonard suskin calls them I don't know
paparan went out of fashion and
philosophy a while ago now most people
who think about the philosophy of
science and philosophy the dominant
tradition is basian we think about this
in terms of probabilities higher
probabilities lower probabilities prior
probabilities and their interaction with
evidence but this this uh this total
concentration on falsification I mean
yeah sure falsification is important but
in general updating of probabilities by
evidence is the more important thing and
by the way yeah some people worry about
the simulation hypothesis that it's not
falsifiable some versions of it might be
falsifiable imperfect simulation
hypothesis the perfect simulation
hypothesis may be not falsifiable in
principle but that's just to say okay
the perfect simulation hypothesis I'm
happy to say is not exactly a scientific
hypothesis still a philosophical
hypothesis poer himself put forward many
philosophical hypothesis that weren't
scientific hypotheses I think it can
still be meaning we come to the end when
I as my thrilling three existential
questions about the meaning of life your
past World line your future history your
gifts to the universe but to watch this
you're going to have to subscribe to my
YouTube channel not you Dave you're
gonna watch it in real time because
you're going to participate in it but uh
you have to subscribe to my mailing list
Brian king.com and there I update and I
provide all the links to David's
wonderful work and his his book of
course that you should buy I listen to
it and read it I think it's just one of
the I think it's your best to date and I
can't wait to see how successful become
so if you want to hear Dave answer the
thrilling three final questions you'll
have to subscribe to the channel and to
my mailing list Brian king.com I'll send
you the link so for now signing off of
this main portion of the episode Into
The Impossible with Dave charers NYU and
author of reality plus a uh guide to
philosopher philosophy's problems and uh
the ultimate answer to the to the uh
perhaps the most important questions of
the Modern Age Dave thank you so much